[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau numéro de
Parlement Hebdo et l'émission qui
revient sur l'actualité de la semaine au
Parlement et cette semaine nous
accueillons Claude Malleret bonjour
bonjour on vous présente plus vous êtes
sénateurs de l'Allier et président du
groupe Les Indépendants Républiques et
territoire au Sénat c'est-à-dire les
sénateurs de droite qui se disent
constructif avec Emmanuel Macron et à la
une cette semaine ce bras de fer
politique qui continue à l'Assemblée
nationale entre la majorité
présidentielle et les oppositions autour
de la réforme des retraites et de la
proposition de loi du groupe lyaute à
l'article d'abroué d'abrogation de la
retraite à 64 ans a été rejetée en
commission la mesure sera réintroduite
le 8 juin dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée mais la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale devrait déclarer
et recevable cette mesure sur le plan
financier le Sénat poursuit son travail
autour de la démission du maire de
Saint-Brevin en Loire-Atlantique victime
à des pressions et des violences de
l'extrême droite le préfet de
Loire-Atlantique et les sous-préfet de
Saint-Nazaire ont été entendus par les
sénateurs une proposition de loi pour
mieux protéger nos élus a déjà été
présenté cette semaine par la majorité
de droite et du centre du Sénat et puis
on parlera de la commission d'enquête du
Sénat sur le réseau social chinois
TikTok dont vous êtes le rapporteur
Claude malurey les sénateurs tentent de
faire la lumière sur la stratégie
d'influence de Pékin via ce réseau
social
mais d'abord le sujet de la semaine les
retraites le départ à 64 heures et pour
l'instant maintenu puisqu'en commission
parlementaire la majorité a vidé le
texte de l'iode de son article clé celui
qui visait précisément à abroger la
mesure phare de la réforme les
oppositions des noces des magouilles qui
visent à empêcher le vote en séance
publique la semaine prochaine
explication avec Marco pommier
pour 38 contre 34 à 4 fois près la
majorité les républicains rejettent
labrogation de la retraite à 64 ans dans
une salle pleine à craquer et sous
tension la nupes a défendu le retour aux
62 ans
proposition de loi et de sa lubriter
publique parce qu'elle vient effacer une
régression méprisable injustifiée
injustifiable le camp présidentiel lui
dénonce l'arnaque de la proposition de
loi défendue par Charles de Courson tout
le monde fait dans cette salle que
jamais cette proposition ne sera votée
au sein tout le monde sait dans cette
salle que cette proposition est
inconstitutionnelle après une victoire
d'étape pour le camp présidentiel la
gauche tente une contre-attaque en
déposant jusqu'à 3000 amendements pour
empêcher les débats d'aller à leur terme
le bureau de la commission décide de ne
pas les examiner obstruction dit la
majorité colère de la gauche contre la
présidente de la commission notre rôle
de parlementaire ne sert plus à
grand-chose nous le constatons et donc
nous partons la nupes claque la porte la
proposition de loi est vidée de sa
substance mais le groupe yote ne désarme
pas je déposerai un amendement
absolument pour
non pas réécrire mais pour remettre le
texte initial voilà réintroduire
l'abrogation des 64 ans par amendements
objectifs obtenir un vote sur cette
mesure jeudi prochain dans l'émission un
scénario peut probable la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale s'apprête à
brandir le coup près de l'irrecevabilité
financière au titre de l'article 40 de
la Constitution je regarderai
l'amendement formellement quand il sera
déposé s'il est déposé s'il revient dans
l'hémicycle je prendrai évidemment mes
responsabilités
déterminer à maintenir la pression
Charles de Courson n'exclut pas le dépôt
d'une nouvelle motion de censure
des affaires sociales cette semaine
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire est-ce que
pour vous tout simplement la majorité
présidentielle a eu peur du vote
alors quand je regarde ça je me dis j'ai
fait une première réflexion c'est que je
suis content d'être sénateur parce que
ils sont en train de transformer et je
suis ça je plaisante pas ils sont en
train de transformer l'Assemblée
nationale en un guignol
et c'est très grave vous trouvez que la
République bien sûr depuis le dernier
élections législatives
la France indigne la France insoumise
comment il s'appelle quand vous dites il
vous visez
que j'appelle la France indigne
qui ont décidé de discréditer
l'Assemblée nationale de la transformer
en ZAD de discréditer nos institutions
parce que c'est ce qu'il souhaite parce
qu'ils veulent la fin de la cinquième
République et le début et la 6e
république bien entendu il n'y
arriveront pas mais c'est le but ça fait
9 mois que ça dure que régulièrement
cette loi comme les lois précédentes
donne lieu à des affrontements en
commission dans l'hémicycle que tous les
Français regardent au point
qu'aujourd'hui moi quand je rentre chez
moi dans l'Allier je vois de plus en
plus de gens qui me disent j'irai pas
voter
pour pour ce théâtre de Guignol ce qui
veut dire que ces portes petit à petit
un coup de plus en plus grave à nous
institutions bien entendu au passage ils
se tirent une balle dans le pied parce
que les gens ne veulent plus non petit à
petit ils perdent de l'influence il
suffit de voir les dernières sélections
législatives les derniers sondages il se
tirent aussi une balle dans le pied je
parle de LFI mais ils sont en train de
disqualifier nos institutions et ce qui
se passe là et et la preuve même vous
l'avez dit dans le reportage cette loi
nous le savons depuis le début vous le
savez depuis le début et comme les
chaînes de télé et de radio on parle
depuis le début ça fait deux mois que ça
dure on s'est depuis le début et on le
répète tous les jours que cette loi n'a
aucune chance de passer et qu'elle est
inconstitutionnelle par conséquent tout
ce qui se passe depuis deux mois c'est
uniquement fait pour
coincer pour ennuyer pour
le gouvernement mais tous ceux qui la
font qui la proposent savent
parfaitement qu'elle ne passera pas et
donc ce qu'il faut aussi dire ce que je
voudrais c'est que vous avez cette
entreprise de démolition de la part de
Luxembourg que l'extrême droite regarde
avec des listes parce que c'est
l'araignée qui regarde la mouche qui va
venir se prendre dans sa toile et on
voit bien que c'est eux qui montent et
vous avez à droite une partie de la
droite vous avez des idiots utiles
pourquoi je dis que je suis content
d'être sénateurs parce que les idiots
utiles de l'iode qui moi je pense qu'il
devrait se méfier on n'a jamais raison
c'est jamais bon de faire applaudir par
ses ennemis ils sont en train de jouer
les idées utiles au Sénat la droite et
notamment les républicains ont une
attitude digne qui consiste à dire on
est pour ça et on va pas changer d'avis
d'un jour à l'autre est-ce qu'il n'y a
pas aussi une entreprise d'empêchement
de la part de la majorité présidentielle
et du gouvernement n'empêchement d'un
vote de l'Assemblée nationale sur cette
réforme de retraité est-ce que c'est pas
ça au fond le problème de cette crise
est-ce que c'est pas un problème
démocratique et à partir du moment où
cette loi n'a aucune chance c'est toi
était inconstitutionnel pourquoi le
gouvernement pourquoi la majorité
présidentielle irait jouer le jeu de
d'aller de continuer ce théâtre dont de
continuer ce guignol qui de toute façon
au bout d'un certain temps sera arrêté
soit par le Sénat et évidemment qu'elle
ne sera pas voté par le général soit par
le Conseil constitutionnel et évidemment
qu'elle sera arrêtée par le Conseil
constitutionnel puisqu'elle est
inconstitutionnelle on va quand même pas
reprocher à la majorité de dire on va de
dire on va abréger les choses parce que
ce que vous faites et n'a rien à voir
avec la réalité non mais au-delà de
cette proposition à proposition à l'iode
il y a la réforme des retraites et ce
que le problème de cette crise des
retraites ce n'est qu'il n'y a pas eu de
vote à l'Assemblée nationale sur cette
réforme si vous voulez dire que toutes
les lois qui ont été adoptées par un
49-3 du temps de Rocard du temps de du
temps de la droite aussi qui a utilisé
souvent le 49-3 quand elle était
majoritaire 43 utilisé des dizaines et
des dizaines de fois pour ne pas sur une
réforme des retraites qui ont non mais
elle a été utilisée sur des lois tout à
fait importante tout à fait importante
et elle fait partie c'est pas par
la Constitution elle a été faite par De
Gaulle elle a été faite par De Gaulle
pour éviter les les l'impuissance de la
Troisième République le 49-3 il est fait
il est fait pour éviter les
gouvernements qui de la Première
République qui changeaient tous les deux
mois parce qu'il faisait mettre en
minorité et par conséquent c'est une
c'est une des forces de la santé de la
5e République alors qu'on l'utilise que
tous les partis politiques que toutes
les majorités l'ont utilisé et
évidemment à toutes les majorités on
leur a dit vous êtes des dictateurs vous
êtes mais mais c'est la même chose
aujourd'hui qu'avant il y a rien de
nouveau après l'utilisation de 49 3 on a
observé que la mobilisation populaire
c'était accentuée qui a eu beaucoup de
manifestations et cette fois la chef du
groupe la France insoumise appelle le 6
juin à une nouvelle à mettre la pression
populaire maximum sur le gouvernement
elle dit est-ce que vous pensez que
cette contestation allumée il y a
quelques mois sur la réforme de retraite
va s'éteindre
oui je pense qu'ils ont ils ont perdu
ils ont perdu le combat lég négatif ils
ont ils ont pas tout à fait perdus parce
qu'ils ont réussi à disqualiser
l'Assemblée nationale mais ça passe le
mot pour cette loi depuis 9 mois il a
transforme quand je disais en une ZAD
une zone à délirer d'ailleurs à mon avis
mais sur ce thème là ils ont perdu je
pense là aussi quand je vais quand je
rentre chez moi le weekend et que je
discute avec avec les gens de mon
département je pense que la situation
n'est pas la même que l'été il y a un
mois ou deux le vote a eu lieu ou le
vote n'a pas eu lieu comme vous voudrez
mais enfin de 49,3 a eu lieu et la
motion de censure a eu lieu parce que
quand vous dites il y a pas de vote il y
a quand même une notion de censure qui a
été déposée et qui n'a pas été votée
c'est un vote ça et aujourd'hui je pense
que les gens je crois les gens que je
vois pas tous bien entendu il y en a qui
continuent à être extrêmement contente
mais se disent et je crois que les gens
ont compris à travers c'est peut-être
une des forces de ce débat qui a eu
beaucoup dans les médias tout le monde a
compris que le système est ne pouvait
pas continuer il était déficitaires
alors on n'est pas content de la
solution certains ne sont pas contents
mais je pense que les gens sans doute
envolent au gouvernement mais se disent
maintenant ça y est le c'est joué
passons à autre chose Claude madurée on
va passer un autre sujet on va parler
des violences à l'encontre des élus
puisque après la démission du maire de
Saint-Brévin en Loire-Atlantique victime
de la violence de l'extrême droite et
bien les sénateurs ont additionné cette
semaine le préfet de Loire-Atlantique et
le sous-préfet de Saint-Nazaire sur
l'accompagnement de ce maire par l'État
dans cette affaire en accompagnement qui
est pointé du doigt et puis cette
semaine la majorité de droite et du
centre du Sénat également fait des
propositions pour mieux protéger nos
élus de ces violences les explications
de Jonathan du priez les explications
des hauts fonctionnaires étaient très
attendues par les sénateurs deux
semaines après la démission du maire de
Saint-Brevin le préfet de région Pays de
la Loire et le sous-préfet de
Saint-Nazaire ont pu répliquer aux
charges de Yannick Morez le maire accusé
notamment le préfet d'avoir menti sur la
tenue de réunion publique préalable à
l'installation d'un centre d'accueil
pour migrants au sein de l'école de sa
ville quand il dit qu'il a organisé des
réunions publiques
je parle de la part d'un préfet mentir
et frontément on a toutes les preuves
celui de lui demander la date il pourra
pas en fournir il en a pas fait face au
sénateur le préfet a tenu à réaffirmer
qu'au contraire l'État n'avait pas
manqué à ses devoirs et avait toujours
soutenu le maire menacé par des groupes
muscules d'extrême droite nous avons la
gendarmerie de sous-préfet moi-même je
crois accorder une attention immédiate
et requise au maire je ne crois pas que
l'État est oubliée de soutenir et
d'accompagner un maire lâchement ciblé
par un incendie et sur ce point les
sénateurs ont essayé de comprendre une
fois le domicile de Yannick Morez
incendié quel soutient l’état a-t-il pu
apporter au maire de Saint-Brévin un
coup de téléphone selon le sous-préfet
mais pas davantage est-ce que l'un ou
l'autre vous êtes allé à Saint-Brevin
pour témoigner le soutien de l'État aux
maires de Saint-Brévin j'ai eu le maire
le jour de l'incendie
je n'ai pas perçu de demande
particulière de sa part à ce moment-là
peut-être à tort mais
j'ai pas ensuite eu le réflexe de
l'appeler pour lui dire je viens je
viens chez vous c'est exact l'audition
des hauts fonctionnaires n'a pas
convaincu les parlementaires mais
l'affaire du maire de Saint-Brévin a
particulièrement touché la chambre haute
qui entend légiférer à nouveau pour
renforcer la sécurité des élus et durcir
les peines envers leurs agresseurs le
maire c'est pas Madame Michou monsieur
Dupont c'est l'incarnation de l'État
donc est représentent l'autorité et on
ne peut pas tolérer d'être dilettante
avec des gens qui portent atteinte à la
République à démocratie ce n'est que ça
cette proposition de loi sera examinée
au début de la prochaine session
parlementaire à l'automne
est-ce que l'État dans cette affaire a
tardé à protéger à accompagner le maire
de Saint-Brévin qui a été victime des
pressions de l'extrême droite ça moi je
suis incapable de répondre je ne connais
pas les détails de la faire comme vous
le voyez il y a une commission du Sénat
qui sait pas qui se penche dessus et ça
a l'air très compliqué donc je ferai
confiance aux conclusions de la
commission mais je suis incapable
aujourd'hui moins de vous dire de vous
dire quels sont les responsabilités dans
cette affaire est-ce qu'il faut durcir
les sanctions pénales contre les auteurs
de violence contre les élus ou pas
écoutez je l'ai demandé dans une
question au gouvernement il y a une
quinzaine de jours et je pense
effectivement qu'il faut défendre les
qu'il faut défendre des élus est-ce que
ils ne sont pas assez défendus
aujourd'hui il y a quand même un certain
nombre de un certain nombre de mécanis
un certain nombre de mesures si on
retrouve les auteurs de l'incendie je
pense que ils vont quand même s'en
souvenir et que les juges ne sont pas et
je pense alors pourquoi pourquoi durcir
les
je pense pas qu'on soit dans une société
et je suis beaucoup de en désaccord avec
beaucoup de gens je suis pas certain du
tout qu'on se donne une société plus
violente qu'avant et je pense même que
si vous consultez les historiens sur le
long terme les historiens vous disent la
société a plus de densation ça se
pacifier après tout je préfère vivre
dans une dans notre époque qu'à l'époque
de mes parents avec les dizaines de
millions de morts de la deuxième guerre
mondiale ou que mes grands-parents avec
les millions de morts de la Première
Guerre mondiale quand j'étais enfant les
enfants étaient battus ça ne aujourd'hui
vous donner une gifle à un enfant c'est
c'est scandaleux il y avait les
martinets étaient en vente libre était
en vente dans les drogueries et après
presque chaque famille il y avait un
martinet chez elle et de temps en temps
on s'en servait enfin je vous parle d'un
temps qui qui n'est pas si ancien que ça
ou les enfants où il y avait des
violences intermédiaires et évidemment
toujours des violences intrants
familiales et notamment des violences
sexistes mais je pense que plus plus ça
va le plus elles font scandale et plus
elle est en revanche sur les
institutions et pas seulement les élus
sur les forces de l'ordre vous le voyez
on voit régulièrement chez sur vos
écrans la contestation des institutions
la constitution de la contestation de la
démocratie et de ceux qui la
représentent me semble être en
augmentation et de
l'une des vous connaissez mon mon
opinion là-dessus l'une des raisons
c'est aussi la montée des réseaux
sociaux Obama dit dans des atlantique il
y a quelques temps Obama qui connaît
bien le sujet dit les réseaux sociaux
sont devenus une des principales menaces
pour notre démocratie moi-même il se
trouve que ça ne me fait rien donc je
vais pas porter de pain mais j'ai reçu
au moment des gilets jaunes au moment
des covides des centaines je dis bien
des centaines de menaces de mort et je
suis pas le seul les les députés mais
mes collègues parlementaires ont eu leur
permanence saccager et tout donc
pénales ça peut diminuer cette défiance
sur les réseaux sociaux je pense pas que
c'est la solution
radicale et définitive mais marquer le
coup et dire
puisque aujourd'hui les institutions
sont plus à que la démocratie qui est
attaquée non seulement de l'intérieur
mais de l'extérieur par les régimes
autoritaires enfin je fais pas de dessin
donc la démocratie est beaucoup plus en
danger qu'elle ne l'était après 90 quand
les régimes autoritaires se sont
effondrés la défense d'aujourd'hui est
donnée un certain nombre de signaux pour
faire notamment réfléchir les plus
idiots qui n'ont pas encore compris que
ça peut leur coûter plus cher je ne
pense pas que ce soit la mesure radicale
et définitive mais elle marque le coup
et je suis plutôt partisan de cette
mesure allez on va poursuivre cette
émission en regardant à l'agenda de la
semaine prochaine au Parlement
[Musique]
à l'Assemblée le 7 juin ce sera le vote
solennelle de la loi de programmation
militaire qui donne plus de moyens aux
armées face notamment aussi Bernadas
et puis le 8 juin la proposition de loi
de l'iode dont on a parlé justement pour
abroger le recul de l'âge de départ à la
retraite elle sera examinée cette
fois-ci en séance au Sénat mardi 6 juin
ce sera le début de l'examen du projet
de loi d'orientation du ministère de la
Justice un texte qui augmente le budget
de la justice et qui crée à 10000 postes
supplémentaires dans l'institution
judiciaire mardi les sénateurs auditions
également l'administrant charge des
professions de santé Agnès Firmin le
Bodo sur la fin de vie car c'est elle
qui va porter le projet de loi sur la
fin de vie et puis jeudi 8 juin au Sénat
la commission d'enquête sur le réseau
social chinois Tik Tok et sa stratégie
d'influence auditionnera les dirigeants
de Tik Tok et justement on va parler de
ce sujet Claude Maghreb puisque vous
êtes rapporteur de cette commission
d'enquête on va regarder un extrait
d'une audition de votre commission
d'enquête l'audition du député européen
Raphaël Glucksman il revenait sur la
décision de la Commission européenne de
bannir l'utilisation de Tik Tok assez
salariée mais selon lui et bien
l'Union européenne n'explique pas assez
clairement pourquoi elle cible ce réseau
social chinois on va l'écouter on a reçu
une note
confidentielle à partager mais j'ai pas
le droit de le faire publiquement qui
explique les risques
elle a pas été communiquée publiquement
d'ailleurs ça c'est une vraie question
c'est à dire
il n'y a pas de volonté d'expliquer
publiquement pourquoi en cible
spécifiquement Tik Tok
[Musique]
c'est de toute façon une mesure de
précaution
c'est à dire que c'est fondé sur l'idée
de risques c'est pas fondé sur
sur
des preuves
d'espionnage avérés même si on a
ces risques sont conséquents et le fait
de ne pas les partager à mon avis
et problématique politiquement
démocratiquement et relève d'une
politique européenne depuis longtemps
qui est de ne pas
antagoniser la Chine
Claude malurey est-ce que l'Union
européenne est trop tendre avec ce
réseau social TikTok au risque de ne pas
pour ne pas froisser la Chine je dirais
surtout
peut-être un petit mot ré elle a quand
même un
mérite c'est que jusqu'à présent
personne n'a rien fait et que c'est la
première à avoir fait quelque chose
deuxièmement elle le fait elle fait ce
qu'elle peut parce qu'elle interdit
l'application à tous ces fonctionnaires
elle n'a pas le droit d'interdire dans
les différents pays européens elle seule
donc elle fait sa partie du job et
d'ailleurs elle a montré l'exemple
puisque depuis dans les qui ont suivi
pratiquement tous les pays européens y
compris en France ont pris la même
décision donc et Raphaël Glucksmann a
raison pourquoi elle ne va pas plus loin
d'abord parce qu'elle ne peut pas mais
pourquoi elle n'explique pas
publiquement et c'est là qu'elle est
prudente c'est parce que elle s'est
parfaite elle sait la raison pour
laquelle est interdit c'est parce qu'il
y a transfert massif de données des
utilisateurs de Tik Tok dans tous les
pays occidentaux en Chine et d'ailleurs
Tik Tok a été forcé à la suite de fuite
qui ont eu lieu à la fin de l'année
dernière Tik Tok a été forcé de le
reconnaître et quand vous savez qu'en
Chine les sociétés de byte dance qui est
la maison Victor sont avec des cellules
du Parti communiste à l'intérieur comme
toutes les sociétés les grandes sociétés
chinoises vous avez là un risque
d'espionnage à partir du transfert de
données qui est majeur pourquoi la
Commission européenne ne le dit pas
parce qu'elle veut pas en venir c'est un
problème diplomatique on diminue les
rapports avec Pékin mais la réalité tout
le monde la connaît c'est un transfert
de données et qui demain peut donner
lieu à de l'espionnage
ont été jusqu'à aller interdire l'usage
de Tik Tok dans leur parlement est-ce
qu'il faudrait le faire à l'Assemblée au
Sénat et pourquoi pas même dans toute la
France vous seriez pour c'est je
j'attends la fin de la commission
d'enquête pour le pour voir les
recommandations qu'on fera moi je crois
que dans un premier temps
le fait de
l'interdire
de l'interdire aux fonctionnaires de
l'État ou aux fonctionnaires en général
c'est important je serai moi si je suis
me demander un conseil si des collègues
sénateurs ou début juillet me donner un
conseil c'est surtout ne télécharger pas
cette application
maintenant évidemment il faut toujours
peser la balance dans un pays
démocratique entre les précautions à
prendre et les dangers à combattre et la
liberté d'expression donc je pense que
de ce point de vue là il faut aller plus
comme je l'ai fait je vous rappelle
l'affaire Russian today et Sputnik j'ai
demandé depuis 1900 depuis 2018
l'interdiction de RT et de Spoutnik en
France qui sont des organes de
désinformation du FSV de Poutine et on
m'a dit à l'époque mais vous n'y pensez
pas liberté d'expression le jour où
Poutine a envahi l'Ukraine du lendemain
RTS et on a compris ce que c'était mais
vous avez toujours c'est une je pense
qu'il faut être plus ferme mais il faut
expliquer beaucoup parce que
immédiatement vous avez le réflexe
liberté d'expression jeudi prochain donc
vous allez auditionner les dirigeants de
Tik Tok quelle question vont être posées
se pose dans cette dans cette audition
des multiples questions à leur poser
j'ai démultiplication
des affaires publiques
premièrement le problème des transferts
de données et de la même mise du Parti
communiste chinois sur l'ensemble by the
dance TikTok c'est dans notre c'est
notre premier point le deuxième c'est la
dictativité c'est un algorithme
extrêmement addictif tout le monde le
sait les mots et d'ailleurs les
associations de parents nous disent mais
faites quelque chose nos enfants on
passe la nuit dessus etc et comme ils
connaissent même informatique que nous
on peut on n'arrive pas à les à les en
empêcher et donc c'est-à-dire algorithme
est beaucoup plus élitif que sur
facebook d'Instagram etc et par
conséquent vous avez là un problème de
développement psychologique de l'enfant
de de
d'apprentissage de connaissances et puis
le troisième point c'est le sujet
censure est désinformations potentielles
donc vous voyez il y a pas mal il y a
beaucoup de questions
et publique donc si ça vous intéresse
n'hésitez pas sur le site on va on va
dire un mot d'une autre commission
d'enquête celle de l'Assemblée nationale
sur les ingérences étrangères puisque le
rapport révélé par Mediapart il n'est
pas encore sorti accuse le Front
national devenu rassemblement national
d'avoir été une courroie de transmission
du pouvoir russe écoutez le président et
la rapporteur de cette commission il y a
un parti politique en France qui s'est
avéré être beaucoup plus que d'autres un
vecteur
[Musique]
privilégié un relais
assez affirmé assez constant de
d'éléments de discours de prise de
position d'un narratif russe et de
discours et maintenant du Kremlin c'est
rassemblement national
certains conclus qu'on serait une
courroie de transmission certains
conclus que nous serions que nous
aurions un rapport accablant sur 10 ans
de compromission avec la Russie mais
rien ne permet aujourd'hui d'établir ces
éléments bien au contraire tout ce qu'il
y a dans les comptes rendus une fois
plus qui sort vos dispositions
permettent d'établir le contraire bien
avant que le rapport soit publié
question Saint-Claude malheureuse que
pour vous le FN devenu à Rennes et une
courroie de transmission du Kremlin
c'est évident et c'est évident depuis
longtemps enfin je l'ai exprimé à
plusieurs reprises au Sénat dans des
questions gouvernement dans des dans des
débats sans doute sur d'autres plateaux
et sans doute sur d'autres plateaux
c'est une évidence d'ailleurs un certain
nombre de ces membres dans le tristement
célèbre Thierry Mariani sont aujourd'hui
dans l'objet d'une enquête judiciaire
en tant qu'agent enfin qui qui qui
essaye de faire la lumière sur le fait
qu'il serait ou non le rassemblement
national est évidemment depuis longtemps
depuis les années des années une
courroie de transmission du Petit Nice
pour reprendre enfin si c'est les
déclarations d'Elisabeth borde sur les
fondateurs qui étaient tennis je dirais
elle a eu raison selon vous Elisabeth
borne de dire ça il y a elle a eu raison
il y a dans le dans les fondateurs du
Front national bien entendu non
seulement des collabos des pétainistes
mais aussi des gens qui étaient dans des
à la Légion développeurs français contre
de l'extrême droite pendant la guerre
donc de pétains à Poutine ça c'est une
évidence je voudrais quand même
rapidement
je suis tout à fait le grip soit sur un
point il y a un particulier le relais
d'influence il y en a un autre c'est les
filles et vous êtes et c'est clair et
vous avez remarqué que le Front National
a voté contre le rapport que tout le
monde a voté pour que la France
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
beaucoup Claude naluret d'avoir été
notre invité cette semaine et merci à
tous de l'avoir suivi
[Musique]